servus s kids und herzlich willkommen
aus meiner letzten berliner nacht morgen
früh war ich zurück nach hause ich zum
und obwohl es jetzt gerade fünf uhr ist
ist da hinten wie man einfach dass
irgendwann auch so nachtschwimmen ich
dachte mir ich zeit mich einfach mal
hier so noch meine gegend in der letzten
nacht ist mega dunkel wie bei dem
friseur habe ich mir immer die haare
schneiden lassen da vorne an der ecke
ist der altes dunkel ist er später bei
dem ich immer eingekauft habe eine cola
geholt habe wenn ich da nachts schlafen
spät unterwegs war der 24 stoffen hat
haben auch mal echt coole leute
gearbeitet dass hier
da
das hier ist der laden da war ich immer
einkaufen und gucken wollte euch heute
noch dieses kleine video mit geben weil
ich weiß immer so ein bisschen doof
finde wenn gar kein video kommt würde
ich einfach nur erzählen dass ich jetzt
wenn ihr das video seht gerade aus
berlin wieder wegziehen wieder zu meiner
familie zieht darüber sehr freue
ich war einfach diese stimmung hier
mitten in der nacht alle autobauer
beschlagen ist es ziemlich ziemlich kalt
eigentlich so cool dass mir gesagt hat
okay das muss jetzt kurz aufnehmen und
ich würde hier einfach mitteilen dass
ich jetzt heute wegziehe aus berlin weil
diese mikro finde wenn ihr aufgeschaltet
ist das wollen wir so passiert gerade
das war es was von mir berlin over and
out war eine anstrengende aber
eigentlich ziemlich coole zeit jetzt
erstmal entspannen und morgen
weitermachen mit einem neuen gaming
video das war es von mir leute bis dann